hearts and Fire
a concert at berlin's be new club the
laid-back melancholy pop music is a
trademark of singer-songwriter David
levitra the guy the voice and his
expression when he sings no words final
songwriter great songwriter extremely
fresh and professional well we did a
music Malcolm the way they make music
with all those instruments with paper
and bottles it's totally crazy bouncing
as a well whether on guitars strings or
plastic bags David lometa appears on
stage with only two other musicians the
band's arsenal of instruments is
impressive but 32 year old the metra is
known above all for his distinctive
vocals
many in the audience are hearing him for
the first time like here in Berlin as
Billina pune comes naturally oberlin
audiences are you steering the best and
everybody comes here to play so that
makes it a bit of a challenge suppose
for lice non-muslim bitten and overhauls
40 he ought to know the Bolivian native
came to Germany ten years ago as a
student three years ago he moved to
Berlin David Lamela has been writing
songs since his childhood in La Paz
searching for his own voice goodna to
lease hath all feel there's a lot of
music or you put on a mask or play a
role like I no other spirit and a zoo
but I try to do the exact opposite with
my music most often I try to be as much
myself as possible on stage my textbook
in my appearance and with my lyrics
meets knock on the metro released his
debut album latitude in April the video
to his first single megalomania shows
two sisters who become strangers to each
other
let me know
sighs
then show
megalomania TSA's megalomania is the
condition of being in love with yourself
I see it a lot in my surroundings and
above all I recognize it within myself
I'm a Vita Amyas herbs David the metra
at home in Berlin the city where he made
his first album and where he finds
inspiration as convenience of moments
from there a few cities you can claim to
call your own in just three years or so
and Berlin is one of those places when
the smoke villanova Mukhlis back at the
be new club just before showtime Dhabi
the Metro no longer suffers from stage
fright even though every concert is
unique and that's not just because each
audience is different is proud to
designer Bentham unfun band sound
different at the start and at the end of
every tour music is like a receptacle
that you always have to fill up with
something new mi vida Vaz noise in the
end it's just a form that we keep
chasing after dvivida knocking that
means a song like spirals will never
again sound like it does tonight in
Berlin
be ours alone
follow the diamond
you